[Applaudissements]
il les a tuées
il les accumule je propose je propose
qu'on appelle tout de suite un
commissariat doit le dénoncer et pour
qu'ils y retournent le voilà raymond
esprit nous on aime la france et nous
sommes loin c'est l'amour apparemment
nous appeler un commissariat oui vous
voyez que me faire vomir
oui bonjour subie au commissariat de
boulogne oui oui bonjour je vous appelle
c'est cyril hanouna en fait je vous
appelle je ne sais pas si vous voyez que
je suis l'animateur basané dites moi je
vous appelle parce que j'ai eu mes
chroniqueurs jean michel maire au nom
direct alors oui on est en direct
exactement qui a donc commis une
infraction dans la rue puisqu'il a lavé
des voitures alors que c'est interdit
est ce que vous pouvez venir le chercher
au plus vite s'il vous plaît
on a une patrouille qui fait un très bon
non ils vont pas fait alors
merci
alors c'est qui sera celle qui sera la
nôtre nettement au d'ici quelques
minutes
oui s'il vous plaît vie parce que je me
sens pas en sécurité
[Rires]